هنا في منطقه الزبير غرب مدينه البصره حيث
مضيف الشيخ كاظم الصرايفي الذي بات من
اشهر الاماكن التي تستقبل وفوده ومشجعين
خليجي 25 اضافه الى سفراء دول الخليج
العربي
في هذه الخيمه وبين دلال القهوه العربيه
الممزوجه بالهيل العراقي استقبل هذا الرجل
البصري سفير المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
العراق عبد العزيز الشمري الذي حرص على
تلبيه دعوته امبارح كان استقبالنا في
المطار استقبال رائع من قبل المسؤولين
الحكوميين بعد ما طلعنا من مطار استقبلنا
الجمهور العراقي يستقبل الفريق السعودي
بمواقب واعلام همم الى فندق الشهداء
اللي شفناه يثلج الصدر همم شيء مو غريب
على اهل البصره مو غريب على اهل العراق
كاظم السرايفي همم ديوانه مفتوح وبيته
مفتوح وقلوبهم مفتوحه لكل همم
المشاركين في بطوله خليجي 25 من دول مجلس
التعاون فاحنا عند اهلنا وما هو غريب
عليهم الكرم وله غريب عليهم
رحابه الصدر اليوم همم من القرائب الامام
الرقبل سعاده السفير جاء بروحه بسيارته من
فندق شيراتون الى الزبير مسافه 20 او 25
كيلو
دلاله على ذلك يدل على الامان والمحبه
محبه اهل البصره لاخوتهم الخليج
احتضان البصره لاحتضان اخوتهم الخليج
اليوم نشوف عندي اخوه اشقاء من الكويت بس
طرشت لهم اللوكيشن جاءوا للمضيف نظيف
لم يتوقف عن استقبال ضيوفه من كافه دول
الخليج العربي الذين فضلوا النزول عنده
الاستمتاع بكل ما هو عربي مصري من اجواء
باذن الله هذه البطوله رحت تبين
الخليجيه ان ان ان ان البصره افضل وان عن
موجود والحمد لله واحنا والله يعني نشكرهم
على حسن الاستقبال ونشكرهم على ما شاء
الله وتبارك الرحمن على هذه الحفاوه وعلى
هذه الجمعه الطيبه
تفوقت المضاعف العربيه هنا على افخم
الفنادق في البصره حيث وجد ابناء الخليج
فيها القلوب مفتوحه قبل الابواب
من البصره منتظر رشيد العربيه